yeah nicholas cage and john travolta
their careers were on a roll in the 90s
and they met
they collided in this movie called
face-off springboarding onto another
john woo movie after broken arrow
because you know why not wrapping some
90s fun here so let's talk about it
[Music]
face off so face off is like i said
another john woo movie after broken
arrow whereas nicholas cage was
hollywood's up-and-coming good guy of
the 90s john travolta was hollywood's
up-and-coming bad guy of the 90s so they
were like you know what let's swap them
so nicholas cage plays bad guy caster
troy john travolta plays good guy sean
archer
and then they get swapped back in which
john travolta plays bad guy caster troy
nicholas cage plays good guy sean archer
see what happens at the beginning of the
movie nicholas cage as bad
guy caster troy kills sean archer's son
sean archer has an axe to grind against
that guy and so in an altercation
nicholas cage bad guy caster troy
goes into what's called the greatest
plot device that leads to anything ever
that's right a coma you can do anything
in a movie with a coma especially in the
decade of the 90s but there's still a
bomb out there that sean archer needs to
find needs to get the information from
caster troy's brother so he has a
procedure done
where they put nicholas cage bad guy
caster troy's face
on sean archer's body they form his body
to look like caster troy and then bad
guy caster troy nicholas cage wakes up
from his coma without a face
which i always thought that was a bummer
in the reflection they only show his
faceless face briefly but he still had
eyelids and lips i always found that
weird i would i'd have
heard he you know he was like just take
one goddamn guess
that'd have been cooler eyes are all
[ __ ] up
anyhow nicholas cage wears john
travolta's face and so
john travolta now plays the bad guy
sounds very convoluted
as i'm saying it probably didn't need to
be that complicated but i made it that
way so i
watched face off for the first time in
forever
and i really i liked it a lot more now i
always liked it but
it being forever since i watched it i
appreciated the
deeper emotional scenes and the
emotional moments this movie actually
threw at me first of all nicholas cage
and john travolta they're so good in
this movie this is actually the movie
where
when people are like nicholas cage sucks
i'm like no but he was in face off i
know he has
other movies that built his cred like
leaving las vegas before this
got him a lot of notoriety but for me
face-off is the movie or i'm like
but he did a good job yeah still he's
crazy as the bad guy and he's having a
lot of fun doing it this movie actually
required a lot more from nicholas cage
and john travolta than
a basic movie would so he feels like
nicholas cage sets the tone for caster
troy it being a movie they always film
these movies out of order so i don't
know
how one thing led to the next when you
see nicholas cage he looks like a
complete maniac you know crazy nick cage
that we know now
john travolta is just the stick in the
mud good guys with the emotional weight
of his life and the death of his son
just weighing on his shoulders then they
swap and john travolta needs to
essentially be john travolta the bad guy
that we know and love but with a
nicholas cage
toned to him a nicolas cage twang in his
voice it's like
looking in a mirror only not he's not
just
john travolta he's john travolta who
actually kind of sounds like nicholas
cage he's not just john travolta he's
like
sasha what the [ __ ] are you doing here
it sounds like nicholas cage and john
travolta went splat which is what it
would sound like and should sound like
nicolas cage i don't get i don't get a
john travolta tone in nicolas cage but
emotionally speaking nicholas cage
played a bad guy and then he needs to
play
a good guy who needs to act like a bad
guy but not convincingly
enough for us just convincingly enough
for the bad guys in the movie but he
doesn't always do a really good job at
it there's this one scene where he
starts a fight in jail and he starts
crying while he's
starting the fight but he needs to snap
out of it and act like nicholas cage
like
he's a conflicted dude in the movie he
feels like a good guy who needs to act
like a bad guy he's just not comfortable
acting like the bad guy even that scene
where he first looks at himself in the
mirror and he just freaks out on the
mirror it's good
[ __ ] even love those slow-mo ridden john
woo emotional moments like when they
both turn their guns they're both on
opposite ends of this mirror so they get
to aim the gun
at the person they hate which is the
person in the mirror
and they get to shoot that person
granted they don't hit jack [ __ ] except
the reflection but you know it works for
them
it's an emotion it's a good moment for
them whereas when i was younger i just
wanted to say okay john travolta i just
wanted to see him be an [ __ ] and okay
yeah and then they're going to fight but
this time
when john travolta came and saw nicholas
cage for the first time and they had
swaps of john travolta's caster troy
nicholas cage sean archer realizes
what's happening
nick cage looks like he's about to throw
up and i would throw up too
and i just it messed me up it was just
emotionally heavy i just
that's a really it's a nightmare
scenario actually you know what
now that i talked about him being in
jail i'm gonna talk about the jail the
jail is the weird thing for me i don't
know why we're dealing it with a movie
where people can swap
faces and surgically look like other
people but you get the feeling that
procedure isn't well known it's like
they were like yeah but
we live in a world where that technology
is possible so let's just have this
prison that's
off the books it has magnetic boots and
looks like a prison that's in the movie
deadlock i don't know why let's just
make a super prison i guess when
nicholas cage sean archer
escapes he needs to be presumed dead and
you know falling into water is a good
way to do that
he's like oh did he survive i don't know
i never found the body i guess who's
that there's something about that prison
i'm always like okay
you're a leap elite more than faces
swapping
it's the magnetic boots i just i don't
know it's something about that they're
in the middle of [ __ ] nowhere you
don't need the magnetic
boots i love going back to these movies
where you're like oh that's thomas jane
in the prison then he got out and became
the punisher this movie actually i feel
like the action in this movie
is more memorable for me than the action
in broken arrow caster troy getting
blasted by that jet engine
flying down that tunnel i [ __ ] you know
when i hear the song somewhere over the
rainbow i no longer think of the wizard
of oz
i think of face off i mean that's not
nothing but the shootouts while
entertaining as hell and a definite step
up from broken arrow aren't what i enjoy
most about the movie what i enjoy most
is the fact that this movie has a
surprising level of emotional
conflict and weight that comes along
with it just the fact that this
asshole's invaded this good guy's life
and this good guy
knows that there's nothing he can do
about it then he has to get his life
back
it's really twisted invasive
thought-provoking dark compelling [ __ ]
though caster troy being a scumbag
he does have a solid dad moment the
scene where he just drags the dude
out of the car and kicks him in the
balls beats his ass any dad would do the
same and i like the fact that good guy
and bad guy both get an emotional
look into the life of the other person
you know not just a look but
it hits them at an emotional level like
when sean archer's wife brings who she
thinks is her husband who's actually
caster troy to her dead son's grave for
his birthday
the son that caster troy actually killed
caster troy has to stand there and watch
her just be an emotional wreck he has to
fester in the consequences and reality
of his actions same with sean archer
earlier in the movie gina grishan she
plays sasha associated caster troy and
he's like one phone call i can have your
kid taken away from you tell me where he
is he just makes these threats to her
and then when he is when he looks like
castor troy
she's like you need to go i can have my
kid taken away you could tell he's just
like [ __ ] i made that threat to her
god that's messed up she doesn't seem to
like the guy he's just she's
in this situation she's probably young
got tangled up with him and
now she regrets it her life's just kind
of captive they both get this emotional
look into the other side of things when
nick cage is there and he's the good guy
but they think he's the bad guy you get
this
look into the villain life and it just
kind of humanizes the villains
i mean they all seem like [ __ ] and
[ __ ]
but you know that bald dude you know
you're like oh i'm sad he died maybe
it's because he has this great line when
you know when any of your friends is
just
looking mopey you know they're just
looking um you know you want to say that
line to him what's the matter
what you look like you just [ __ ] your
mother come on let's go relax huh
there's just that scene when nicholas
cage is hanging out with castor troy's
associates and you're like
that'd be fascinating to just be in that
situation for a day if they didn't know
who i was it's a neat look into the
other side that can only be
felt if you're seeing the movie through
a good guy's eyes who looks like a bad
guy when the movie goes into its
final third act action ridden throwdown
it's
it starts when they get on the boats it
starts to feel a little long which
shortly after that it does end i do love
at the end of this movie
sean archer doesn't seem to have talked
the adoption over with his wife
he just kind of like nods like is it
okay
i guess so it's a pretty big deal it's
did you talk it
over it's he seems to like just land
this this kid on them like hey
here's a surprise surprise daddy's home
and then you know hi
i'm that's a weird that i think that is
a john travolta thing not that hard
i know you need a thing but i don't know
families have things
how about a bop on the nose wouldn't
that be great it was like hi i'm jamie
[ __ ] is wrong with you your family is a
friend this is weird [ __ ] i'm out of
here in the end face-off is a solid john
woo
90s action movie but it's not just
action
face-off is a solid movie worth watching
and worth buying on blu-ray you know
funny thing sean archer's blood type is
o negative and casters is a b
so caster is the universal receiver
and sean archer is the universal donor i
don't know what that means
but that's their blood type all right so
face off have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more you